[Music]
nora and zeki are on a mission
to protect their village from an alien
few of the villagers are imprisoned by
the alien
they have been assigned the task of
freeing them
but it's not that easy they cannot just
enter
and free the villagers as it's heavily
guarded by a protective layer
if anyone tries to pass this layer then
he would disappear forever
after thorough research and observations
nora and zeki
finally have a breakthrough they find a
code to disable this layer
they find out that for some time in the
evening the alien takes a nap
this is when they can enter the code and
disable the layer
however the problem is that once the
code is entered
the protective layer is disabled for
only 45 seconds
and it can be disabled only once so in
45 seconds
they have to enter the den of the alien
and free the villagers
and come out hey this is ganesh here
from don't memorize
before we get to the solution of this
riddle don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and hit the bell icon
so that you never miss a video from us
okay back to where we left off
zeki decides that he will be the one who
will free the villagers
and nora would be the one who would keep
track of time
they just have to measure 45 seconds and
accordingly get the villagers out
sounds easy isn't it well it would have
been easy
if they had a watch on you see they've
forgotten to wear their watches
so now this task seems like mission
impossible isn't it
but nora doesn't give up so soon she
checks in her bags for some equipment to
measure the time
and she finds just what the doctor
ordered two ropes and a lighter
she knows that both the ropes take
exactly 60 seconds to burn from end to
end
but then the problem is that the ropes
do not burn at a constant rate
so what do you think will they be able
to free the villagers on time
why don't you pause the video and try
solving it
to know whether they made it keep
watching the video
nora did measure out 45 seconds and
within this time
zeki also freed the villagers thus
saving humanity
but how let's have a look
nora has to be quick as she does not
have time
she has two ropes which would help her
in measuring out 60 seconds
but she can neither cut one rope into
two hubs assuming that it will measure
30 seconds
nor can cut the second rope into four
halves assuming it will measure 15
seconds
that's because the ropes do not burn at
a constant rate
no luck here so how would she go about
it
nora takes a look at the rope once again
she does know this fact that both the
ropes take
exactly 60 seconds to burn from end to
end
and that's when it hits her that this is
the key to this puzzle
confused don't be let's understand this
well with the help of a relatable
example
okay now imagine a road which is 120
kilometers long
for our convenience we shall mark these
points as
a and b let's assume that the road isn't
uniform
thus the speed of the car will also not
be uniform
yet the car always manages to cover this
distance in 60 minutes
that is if the car starts from point a
it would take exactly 10 minutes to
cover the first 30 kilometers
it would take another 30 minutes to
cover the next 30 kilometers
and further the car would travel the
remaining 30 and 30 kilometers
in 5 and 15 minutes respectively
that sums up to 120 kilometers in 60
minutes
now let me ask you a question what's the
total distance traveled by the car in 30
minutes
let's try solving it in 10 minutes
it travels 30 kilometers so let's just
write 30 here
okay for the next part we need to find
the distance traveled in the next 20
minutes
tricky right here we know that in 30
the car travels 30 kilometers which
means it travels at the speed of one
kilometer per minute
so now can you tell me how much distance
will be traveled in 20 minutes
that's correct 20 kilometers we write
this 20 here
here it is in 30 minutes car covers 50
kilometers
thus we can establish here that in the
next 30 minutes
the car will cover the remaining 70
kilometers
okay now consider this scenario
what if the car starts from point b
instead of point a
then it will cover 30 30 30 and 30
kilometers
in 15 5 30 and 10 minutes respectively
now let me ask you the same question
which i'd asked you before
what is the total distance traveled by
the car in 30 minutes
in 15 minutes it travels 30 kilometers
we write 30 here in 5 minutes it travels
another 30 kilometers
we write 30 year ok
now comes the interesting part we know
that it takes 30 minutes to cover these
30 kilometers
so by applying the same logic we can say
that in 10 minutes
it travels 10 kilometers here you go
in 30 minutes the car travels 70
kilometers
thus we can establish here that in the
next 30 minutes
the car will cover the remaining 50
kilometers
so if there are two cars at points a and
b
moving towards each other and they start
at the same time
then they would meet each other exactly
after 30 minutes
that is half the time taken to travel
the entire distance
bingo now you may say what if we change
the kilometers
will this still work yes it will
now imagine a road stretching up to 100
kilometers
and this is the distance traveled in 10
5 10
and 5 minutes respectively that is 30
minutes in all
if you observe here as well we shall
find that
if two cars move towards each other then
their time of intersection
would be half the time taken to travel
the full distance
that is 15 minutes now nora gets a hold
of a strategy
to calculate 30 seconds that is
nora would ignite both the ends of the
row we know from what we've seen earlier
that
if the rope is lit on both ends
simultaneously
then it would burn out precisely in 30
seconds which is half of 60 seconds
here nora is able to measure 30 seconds
but then what about the remaining 15
seconds
it will definitely come from the second
row
how would she go about it well
she applies the same logic confused
let's look at the strategy and know how
nora saved the day
okay we know that nora will ignite both
the ends of the first rope
simultaneously
but here's the catch at the exact same
time
she will ignite one end of the second
rope too
now when the first rope completely burns
off nora knows that 30 seconds have
passed
so now nora has measured 30 seconds
this means nora is left with 30 seconds
on the second row
how much more does she want to measure
that's right
15 seconds can you tell me
how can she measure 15 seconds from
these remaining 30 seconds
think about it yes exactly
if at this exact moment nora ignites
this end of the second row
then she would be sure that this rope
will burn off in 15 seconds
that is half of 30 seconds and that's
how she can measure 45 seconds in
all by measuring 30 seconds from the
first rope
and then 15 from the second eureka
and within this time zeki can free the
villagers
they implement the strategy and
successfully complete the mission
nora's logical skills did prove as the
savior of humanity
interesting isn't it now before signing
off here's a question for you
what if instead of 45 seconds nora had
to measure 50 seconds
how would she devise the strategy for
the same
share your strategies in the comments
section
and for more interesting riddles do
subscribe to our channel
good luck with solving